okay for people who are joining us this
is a late-breaking item for version 12
of off language this is about n-body
simulation and it's a kind of an
experimental function for doing and body
simulation as the name might suggest
okay so we're gonna review this
documentation and so on alright so what
why is there a separate page for n body
simulation data represents the results
from n body simulation that's reasonable
enough um shouldn't this also say
interpolating function
um actually should it's a nd solve value
rather than just nd solve here wait
actually it actually uses nd solve but
it could say it could say nd solve value
and interpolation yes I think that's
appropriate
um I think also these things oh another
one that is it is it in any way related
to system model plot not that I know of
all right so what was that in red I
don't know that's a that's a bug that
showed up this morning I have no idea
why when you put in three associations
as rules it's giving a syntax colouring
error okay alright so that's just a bug
of today okay notice also that the font
is wrong um the sushma if you can note
that and see that in that error message
there that font is wrong okay yeah um
okay so let's take a look at what this
actually does so simulate a three body
problem in two dimensions is that a okay
is this the simple
okay so can you give I could just give
two bodies but yeah those three bodies
is pretty much the simplest case then
yeah okay all right so let's take a look
here what it was Abbi oh I was reading
it as baths and one okay so maybe it
should just be a sus in one one or
something like that um but names be sub
I so you can't give Alyssa two it has to
be an association is that true it's a
list of associations nobody understand
but can the names that work on this
outer thing be an association I can't
honestly remember if I if I if I made
that work or not I mean we certainly now
also if you don't name the bodies can
you just have a list of associations
there well you need you need some sort
of body names but yes we could we could
make that work where the body names
would be index numbers now I avoided
having having just index numbers for the
body because like in that first example
we give a time T equals four well we
also part of the part of the rules if
you say quote b1 it gives all the data
for body one in terms of interpolation
function so there's a possible ambiguity
between a time and an integer index
right that's that's why I change to use
these these string names I don't I think
that's not great because I think that
one would like to have um one would like
to be able to have any number of bodies
here
these are nice examples well thank you
this is
this is sort of the ones we'd set up
when we did the the initial review on
this here by the way you shouldn't use
in these examples you should use the the
actual entity I don't see why you should
write it out as entity like this and
also you really shouldn't use you should
just use the thing that you get by doing
um
look oops why doesn't that do it but you
just just get the thing that is um I
mean if you do evaluate in places for
that right Oh fine okay similarly here I
don't really see the reason why you
don't just do a value 8 in place just
don't think that way Seifer yes you've
got a good point I mean it doesn't help
- it doesn't really
great you should probably pull out some
actual results here that is mm less
trivial than just showing that there's
that if you look at my blog post about
the eclipses they're a bunch of
coordinate systems and things where you
can actually see all kinds of
interesting things about the earth-moon
distance for example okay I think for
example I'm sure if I do this if I
compute this let's try running this in
fact I would imagine what I can do here
is to take the distance from the earth
to the moon right position I mean like
for example just the earth-moon distance
oh sure that's a good that's a good idea
yeah so what would it be just know just
be norm don't I'm not sure the mom works
with the unit's properly but there you
go
lovely it's a pity that those things
collide
UPS functional time
okay so let's review again stuff up here
okay so properties given an association
through time T okay fine it's okay okay
goose results gives results in terms of
gives gives a an n body simulation
object as a result right yes um we don't
tend to do that that way we say an
association not why don't we give these
first named
we know possible named possible named
potential laws include possible named
laws
what is gravitation Newtonian gravity
right right so MV square law with what
with what parameter you turn in gravity
with the gravitational constant well
what's with the inverse square law it it
it just takes you know it's basically
like G equals 1 okay with with the
gravitational constant yes that you did
that gravity uses a gravitational
constant Coulomb's law with does that
use with electric yes it uses electric
and you have to specify you have to
specify a charge for your bodies okay um
okay Coulomb's law with physical charges
what is the force okay so what are the
units for these things um potential
force loss will be given as named law a
function or an association okay so if
it's a function what is what do you give
it if it's so so you give it see this
this was a part of the the whole thing
we worked out so we give we give the
cowboy um well it's not document it is
right it's not document we need to
figure that out to write that down it's
basically you give the you know you give
a function where you put in the you know
like you do you know pound one of mass
you know fee so you should give use the
body properties in the body of the
function with the arguments are the two
bodies okay
possible named okay so I'm sorry but
what are you saying here so so you would
give you would give something like you
know so say you wanted to do DT inverse
square law you'd give something for the
potential you give something like you
know slot one of quote mass and slot to
quote mass okay hold on we're also going
to say um okay so the thought it's just
about when names of bodies are given as
entities such as
control equals whoops not working
control equals fascinating such as that
right such as earth properties such as
mass I'll determined automatically yes
okay so what you're telling me is that
then what the minimal case here that I
can do will be something like um I will
be able to say and bodies simulation of
a gravity comma so can I just do this
earth comma moon does that possibly work
well I don't have no it doesn't work
because because I haven't you know that
that would be a whole development
project to try to get so so when when do
you start you start with the current
data what what are your no that's why
that example was so complicated because
I had to get I had to sort of get
initial conditions okay so here here I
could say position arrow i suture say i
suture say um right so it's not
completely obvious what what that does
for us right well that's that's that's
what that example did in fact I think I
had to get the I had to sort of do an
estimate of velocity from cuz cuz it
wasn't it wasn't clear for me how to get
it from the entity framework directly it
you know the velocity the orbital
velocity in any given time
right someone's comments gonna
livestream um it's one of them no no if
you want both gravity and Coulomb's law
you need to give you need to give a
combined um you need to specify that
separately we're not we're not letting
you give the physical properties I mean
you know arguably here you know this is
a bit confusing because okay using
physical using okay so inverse-square
doesn't use mass does it or does it use
mass yes it uses mass okay so does
harmonic use mass as well so everything
uses mass for inertia right an
inverse-square and gravity use mass for
for the coupling for the strength of the
force as well that's correct
yep okay okay so okay so first of all
okay so this is a time wait a minute
what is this so this is where's the
initial condition being given that's
that's that's you you give position and
velocity and that's the initial
condition okay yeah someone's comment on
the livestream looking at the orbital
elements will be a good thing we agree
um okay so let's start this from the
beginning again okay so first of all I
think we should say law because it's a
single law well yes yes then the
simplest case but it can be it can be a
combination of things so you could give
a you know an association with a bunch
of laws and showing an external force it
simulates the system of end bodies with
names Bo and properties and initial
properties well and properties comma
governed by system bodies for time for
time T simulates for time T well we
should say generates a simulation
generates a simulation of the motion of
a system of n bodies with names and
properties given a it's a simulation of
the motion of the system embodies :
the specified potential for slaw over
the course of time over over at the
interval of time T over an interval over
length of time T okay so the very first
thing to say um okay um so the potential
or for slaw um can be given in the form
can be given or for slaughter can be
given as and now we need to I think of a
list of the cases here which are quotes
named named law then we need to say an
association here um basically ki-10 now
are those functions or names typically
canari functions um law with specified
properties only matters what to say prop
1
okay and now the third case is a
function to be applied to configurations
is that correct what what does that
function do well so so in that in the
pairwise so for each of those and maybe
maybe we should put you know the
pairwise potential and describe what the
function looks like then
so the function basically takes as
arguments that the associations for the
tube for example in the pairwise case it
takes the associations but can you give
a single naked function as the law yes
okay what is it applied to then it's
what it depends that's what I'm trying
to say so in the pairwise in the
pairwise case so paranoid on pairwise
force it's applied to the associations
for the two bodies and I know it's how
much you're saying but I'm saying this
is an alternative for the whole
potential force law okay so is it the
case that you can give a function as the
complete thing not an association that
says pairwise potential arrow whatever
but a function this first argument
function if if you only give a function
if you only give a function it's
interpreted as a pairwise potential okay
okay
okay fair enough okay so now possible
named laws include and now they're these
okay I think we should give the harmonic
potential next after this one um sure
okay okay inverse square law with unit
unitless inverse square law is that a
first taste and then unitless harmonic
potential Newtonian gravitation with
units Coulomb's law with units okay now
um with physical units say physical
units I think that's reasonable
okay you know is this still chain time
to change this to Newtonian sure sure we
just we can easily change that
I think it's better since it's a pity
that attorney inharmonic okay fine
because you're just gonna call it
Newtonian not Newtonian gravity I think
so it's a Newtonian potential as opposed
to a Coulomb potential okay fine okay um
when the laws the following keys can be
used when the law has given us an
association and you called the word
potential function no that's okay okay
powers potential function between any
two bodies so what is that pairwise
Force function between any two bodies
potential function applied to all bodies
is that correct you know potential
function applied to each body additional
potential function applied to each body
yes
okay um okay so now what are these
functions force and potential for
potential and force functions
okay so pairwise potential functions are
applied to are applied to to the
Association is that list now the
arguments they applied to the to the two
associates oh so you could put I mean
you might want to put just pairwise
functions are applied to the
association's well pairwise potential
force functions or force functions F are
applied to the association's we usually
say I saw here okay right I applied as f
of a sock as a sock I a sock J to the
associations representing the states of
bodies I and J that correct yes
why don't we send States given an
assault yeah that's better than
properties should we not name it assault
but name it state one body one arrow
state one I think that was much clearer
it would be clear then that's a good
reason to do it okay we just want to
make it clear that I need to be
associations though given and and States
state I given as associations with names
body I and States state I given as
associations you know what let's not say
that come by the specified potential
force law or the length of time because
we can say um the states are by ok gives
has um the names of bodies are typically
strings well not necessarily know um the
states state I are given as associations
and what about the position yeah okay
given as associations containing the
following elements and then we can and
our charge is optional right yes and you
can also
you know other other Allen depending on
your force law you can put in whatever
elements you want I see um you could put
containing elements including the
following well are any of them
compulsory math position and velocity
are compulsory okay then let's leave out
charge here well yes so no are given as
associated containing the following
elements additional elements used by
particular force potential force laws
can also be included
um potential force laws can be given as
possible named laws include foreign keys
can be used by giving okay pairwise
potential lowers potential or force
functions f are applied applied at each
step at each step in computing the mode
and are applied applied at each step
given a pairwise up a pairwise a
pairwise or potential force function f
is applied at each step in the
computation - hmm you see I'm trying to
say because we want to show this F of
state one state state I state J yeah but
using step is a little it's actually
excited okay okay okay pairwise butter
is applied to all pairs applied for all
the bodies I&J in the form yes um we
should say something about how the units
have to be have to make us some sense um
[Music]
okay so okay um and body simulation
let's see you're trying to say it's got
to have the initial conditions here
actually why don't we just say an
initial state state I yeah okay now
let's look at the word should say fan
body simulation data cuz that's where
you're extracting the state right um
okay wait a minute
the values in the states of each body
can be given as quantities with units
um can I suggest that we might start
with like a like something super simple
like a harmonic oscillator here I mean
it's nice to start with the three-body
problem by the way is this thing with
with entities does it really help us at
all or is it just a total mess I think
because I think it's too complicated I
think right okay amusing that works
right now but okay so let's try and
understand what would happen if we were
just doing n body simulation of okay so
now let's say harmonic by the way this
needs auto-completion i want to come um
okay so it's a little bit awkward that
you know this business with it not okay
so let's take a look at this so how do I
give the spring constant for the whole
molecule attention you would use you'd
use something like our list of harmonic
comma spring constant great okay so in
the case of in these cases with with
unit um in inverse square and harmonic
[Music]
unit multipliers
well inverse square a what what is it
called that the UM you called the
the inverse-square constant or harmonic
by default uses well you know we could
we could specify this is it the case
that harmonic okay so are you then
saying harmonic comma comma K harmonic
potential with spring constant K is that
correct okay no it works a little bit
differently than that so what you do is
you'd give list of harmonic and then you
give option so so easy things they were
set up to do option so you do harmonic
list of harmonic comma then spring
constant goes to whatever and then that
also has an option equilibrium length
okay um
by default harmonic uses unit spring
constant and unit equilibrium length it
actually uses zero equilibrium length
should I change that to unit what if the
equilibrium line could mean then well it
means you start you start with with a
zero length spring and you stretch it
out okay from zero I think you mean unit
unit length would be okay to constant
one and equilibrium length one okay I
will change that right now fact since
I'm looking at the code
um okay so this is the cases where you
can say harmonic and then you can give a
specification here is that true for any
of the other ones as well or not no I
don't think I set it up for the other
ones for let me check to make sure there
you know there are a whole bunch that
Michael had that we haven't included yet
that have the potential for that but
like Warner oh there's like the you call
potential and this and that and and but
those have not really been set up to
work with the current framework because
I haven't had basically do that right I
need input from somebody Michael's group
fine
probably Michael himself yes I default
constant um yeah no inverse
doesn't allow now I could I could allow
a constant there are you doing an
association of parameters here well I
set them up as options so they could be
they could be an association um okay so
this is equilibrium length what do you
usually call the coroner thanks al
yeah yep I don't like to use Ln okay I
mean this is still an experimental
function we let me just make a note here
that we probably want is the occult n
shal with parameters or no yes it's with
parameters no I mean I came up with
physical units or not I set it up
without without units cuz it's a future
thing just remember that okay there's a
bunch that Michael given me including
you Colin Jones as fun or Jones was
there let me look and see what else is
there a little Jones has old kind of
parameters right exactly most of these
had you know various parameters yeah
there's lennard-jones soft Coulomb
pseudo harmonic born Myers Morse
Rockingham good potentials yeah
potential one might say okay okay so
let's just try and give the harmonic
case okay so you're saying I mean it's
very lucky that we have to give
this is very yucky let's take a look at
that I guess that relates to the other
function so let's bring up the other
function now um well yeah it's a you
little yucky Steven but compared to
actually doing the equations and stuff
it's no no I understand but the issue is
whether we insist whether we allow the
possibility of the n-body simulation
data of just B sub I do you get what I'm
saying because that that's the case that
is ambiguous
that's the yes right and and we can we
can technically disambiguate it by you
know
Union a floating point as a you know T
you know to dot is a talk that's that's
that's gonna confuse people for sure at
some point so what's a better way I mean
if we simply said you specify it as n
body simulation data of blah come out
all for example if you just want what
could you have as or blog on automatic
if you want the end case there you go
what I'm saying see I wouldn't be
horrified if this had to say at time T
for a body you want to specify it for
all bodies here right oh that's what you
that's what you're giving there right
well the question is which one wins is
that the body or the time I mean we
could say all comma four I would hardly
seemed to me dramatically horrible and
in other words if you give only one
argument
it could be disappear I don't think
that data of all four is is unreasonable
because that that kind of emphasis are
you getting getting all the bodies yeah
right so then then that disambiguates
okay so what this is saying is we could
just stay so here by the way this is
completely wrong if I might say so that
you forgot that right oh gosh yes thank
you
okay right the other case
to disambiguate is that next last one we
should probably just have you know the
body there's I mean just get rid of that
case okay hold on hold on okay so this
case here is a little funky yes
was that the case you were talking about
or different second about the next you
know so if we if we by itself exactly um
so are we getting rid of the T by itself
case I think we shut Conaty okay okay
fine and then we can also I know that we
need to document this we could we could
support a list of bodies then in that
first argument easily yeah that's a bad
thing
why don't we just do that okay okay so
let's um well then we could we could
just now is it is it going to give an
association like this or is it going to
give a list I think it's gonna give a
list in that case in other words you
know you got what I'm saying yeah it's
we give a list and the the fact that
returns an association means that
actually so as your original question
will it accept an association of muddy
rules and the answer is yes because I
process it in that form okay because the
Association gives a list of a simulation
data gives a list of simulation data
okay so comma all listen this
documentation needs to be cleaned up
this isn't the right way to do it
because comma all for the time should
give the whole interpolating function I
think or should give something that
represents a time series I don't what
you want to give a time series and
interpolating function the usual thing
for for this will be to give a time
series well yes it's in a triplet
function so right thing here okay fine
but then what is going to be the if you
give if you say comma all you can't give
a pure function as the result you have
to give something that is you know that
you can just feed right into you get
what I'm saying well if you just don't
give the T it gives you the
interpolating function are you telling
me that or is that a new idea no that's
that's that's that's I think that's the
way it's always worked okay okay okay so
so what you're saying is um okay all
right represents
south of an n body simulation of an n
body simulation okay um generates an M
body simulation object okay given I
wonder do we have a document in this
because really this is useless without
do we ever documental sub values up here
I don't think we had couldn't I didn't I
didn't I haven't seen any precedence for
that because I like your nearest
function as an example yeah what is it I
don't remember but I think I might have
modeled this on nearest function yep
okay okay um okay so then what we've got
to say is n body simulation data dot dot
of B sub I gives a function representing
the position is it correct representing
the position it gives the it gives that
it gives all the state properties okay
there's a function representing the
state of body well it doesn't quite do
that it gives it gives this the state
where the the position and velocity are
functions of time maybe that's
the right thing maybe we should write it
as a as a pure function that like a
suggestion that we don't document the
one arguments of value case I think
that's fine okay man me that's why I
didn't do it he may have discussed that
before night just for God well I think
that if we don't document that and you
should just never do nothing right and
then we can figure out what the most
convenient thing for it to do is later
fine okay Stephen if you look at such
result object documentation it documents
all these things in a nice table if you
wanna search result object yes that's
interesting idea that's easier to read
with the object yes ah the only problem
is this a multi argument cases well
actually this is obj yeah so we just
replace n body simulation data with obj
right right right right right
um the following
okay okay so now you're saying okay so
obj let's call it n vst's just for that
covet and bsd maybe okay of B sub I
simulation data
well state of body B body B sub I at
time T okay okay n BSD and BSD off um
now it's the all okay so let's get BB B
one B two states of bodies actually
we're going to say body B at time yes
it's a bodies B sub I at time T then the
next case is states of all bodies
I'm T okay right next case
um okay so that's those three cases
right yes okay now next case is a
particular property or list of
properties it's it will include only
that property is that correct yes it
includes only that property but it still
gives it an association no it gives it
it gives it as without the Association
and the read isn't the reason we came up
with it at that particular thing is that
it makes it before we had that thought
funk the plotting stuff okay you just
put I mean mining mill just put a dollar
dollar to indicate or bodies yes that is
comma property value of property prop at
time T values doesn't matter value let's
do body let's do B value of property
props for body B okay
at time T and then let's list the values
because that's what it is
Lester values of prop for for multiple
bodies at time T okay now you've got a
list of properties now and we didn't
didn't didn't Oh didn't support that
because that's really can get that from
the Association from the verbs to if you
want to list a bunch of different things
okay so I I think this case here where
you give you're giving that instead a
right body's gonna do [ __ ] I think if
you want I think this is wrong I think
we should say all comma kinetic energy
call mighty fine
okay to put I mean the well the Prado
the problem is visited ocimum rotation
because they read after support or to
say the kinetic energy for body 1 and
body 2 that's correct okay
pair wise so cheap
it's that right value
use of combined quantities value of a
value of a combined quantity at a time T
ok possible combined quantities include
now we should say here that it solves
the classical equations of motion and
bodies simulation
solves classical normals of a stick well
but a default solves classical non
relativistic equations of motion right
maybe that should be said at the top
since it is kind of critical
okay now possible combined quantities
include okay what's this thing here so
those are those are those are just
properties of the simulation okay so
that's another thing here yeah
you know I'm telling you that the the
whole business with left-handed people
being discouraged against with my sis
just terrible you don't even understand
what I'm saying it's because the things
I have to press because it isn't because
I have a left mouse yeah hold down key
well I can if I if I really cheat here
but um okay I'm telling you that's an
underrepresented underrepresented group
left-handed yes um okay and then we just
need to rewrite that that line about
this simulation properties yes I know
okay possible combined quantities
include no sophistic kinetic energy okay
I left dangling purposes just as you do
yeah bad um simulation interval I think
total simulation yes
or shouldn't that be just maximum
total simulation I mean it's not obvious
to me that you want to start at T equals
zero in all cases but we'll look first I
hugged you know the piece of crap I
rolled at some point but okay yeah there
are cases if cases in the example where
it can't simulate to the requested the
requested time because you have a
collision right I think this should
reference system model even though these
two things don't quite meet yet um okay
all right so now we were just gonna look
at the the harmonic okay so hold on we
actually got another thing we're gonna
look at here we've got it we've got to
change this right so you've got to fix
these so that they always work this way
right yes and then okay so here the
first case of this okay let's just do
this um the first case here will not
even give names to the bodies right
state 1 state 2 state 3 and it's a
simulation system of n bodies okay
that's actually um
Oh States state I gamba specified over
length of the length the time okay now
here I think we should document this as
an association yeah fine I'm happy to do
that because there then then those rules
can naturally come out as associations
for the fine generates a simulation of
the motion of system and bodies with
names body I um okay okay
nice alright so then the minimal case
here is a harmonic potential we can add
this example later okay I think we're in
good shape here so the one thing we need
to do here is to knit this the other
places oh come on guys is that system
model doesn't even well I wonder what
system model doesn't
system model simulation
okay all right now let's figure out
where in earth we're gonna put these
things on our um okay so this a number
of obvious places to put them uh let's
go to guide pages of main page okay so I
can think of some weird places to put
them like in physics let's see um
physics and chemistry astronomical
science what about that
[Music]
you
okay now it's that place let's look at
physics
well it's interesting
I wonder whether we should include that
yeah for me other models um I guess we
can say simulations and we can I can say
and he solve and body a simulation just
for good measure we can include solar or
tortimer
sure um okay
I like Kellis structure we don't need
that there um I Chanukah systems weren't
earth does that link no irrelevant based
models okay where does it fit in this
page about scientific models
I mean arguably in calculus based models
I guess we should put it in that page um
not really right dynamical systems I
think it's really right yeah I think it
is right for that for that list okay
then it probably goes before yeah
next and the solvus right okay then it
needs to go on bizarrely on the calculus
page um but we don't even have any salt
they're doing let's put it at the bottom
and let's point it turn D solve
well there is nd salt right there at the
top but third row under numerical
calculus Oh
oh it is there okay well then we could
put and body I guess we could put n body
simulation there as well it's a little
weird young mature it fits on this page
honestly we have a we must have the page
for differential equations in general
though I'm not sure I don't think we
have that many functions right two
differential equations do a video it's a
guide differential equations which is
cool down it's actually a link to this
page well scoot down all the all the way
to the bottom I'm not saving it it shows
up under the related guides in calculus
but I'm looking at the oh there yeah
okay well then maybe it doesn't belong
on this page I think it would be better
on that page then maybe what we want to
say
it's a little weird that it's not on
that page should we put simulations down
here and bodies simulate yeah I think
that would be fine well I think we
should include system model here
okay so now we've pushed this back here
this is a little weird to have calculus
based models and bodies simulation but
now you know what I'm gonna remove that
from that and I'm gonna probably give it
its own category and by the way just
system model appear on this page that's
totally weird that should be here
I see systems modeling in the related
guides section I think it should be on
this page I think it should by DM system
model
and then here we should say n-body
simulation because it's really a
category of modeling they think I mean
there's probably other things like
blades and so on which is really should
be part of this and body simulation and
for the sake of having another thing to
put here I don't know I don't know
that's a DQ a question I don't know the
answer to um okay here that should link
and I'm running out of time here so that
should link to the system's model
systems modeling page here hopefully
that water link if I do this um
hey where else should this go we put it
in first
we put it in astronomy um over Paris
questions on livestream is this function
paralyzed no hopefully it will be one
day
well yeah Marc Marc Marc just entered
his pero pero real method for nd solve
so it's it's it's possible and that
becomes mainstream we'll be able to do
that can we remember to do it I mean
well it's that the methods not methods
not ready yet it's you know it it works
but it doesn't really speed things up
okay
let's just think about where else we're
gonna put this anybody I think this is a
reasonable place I think it's yeah I
mean I think differential equations page
is really important and physics um okay
I mean that seems to cover it ah well it
kills structure and computation that's
we're gonna want those other potentials
right I know but
all the trip potentials ie you can get
them yourself
okay okay I think that does it all right
more examples dad hopefully you can get
some stuff in before the freeze today
well that may not be realistic back and
I'll just put in bug reports that we
don't quite match the documentation okay
okay I'm gonna push this documentation
back thank you all
look I'll talk you'll soon